these images just released by the
Brazilian Congress show how the attack
on the capital unfolded one week after
the inauguration of President Louisiana
Silva thousands of supporters of former
president
stormed the presidential Palace Congress
and the Supreme Court in an attempt to
overthrow the new government 1 500
people were detained nine days after the
Rampage the first group of suspects have
been indicted 39 defendants have been
charged with armed criminal Association
violent attempt to subvert Brazil's
democracy and damage to public property
prosecutors have requested that the
defendants be preventively detained and
over 7 million dollars of their assets
be frozen president Lula da Silva also
dismissed 40 military personnel from the
presidential Palace last week he accused
members of the security forces of
helping the rioters
many officers were collaborating with
writers many people in the military
police were complicit many people from
the Armed Forces here inside were
complicit I am convinced that the door
of the plan Alto Palace was opened so
that these people could enter because
there is no door that has been broken
down additional rioters are expected to
be charged in Brazilian authorities are
also investigating Who helped finance
and plan the attack bolsonaro left
Brazil before Lula's inauguration and is
in Florida on a diplomatic Visa but with
Brazil's Supreme Court investigating his
role in the riot and growing calls to
revoke his U.S visa the former president
is soon have to return home to faces
accusers Monica and archival Jazeera Rio
de Janeiro